in 2015 Volkswagen covered up a scandal
that affected millions of cars and cost
the company 30 billion there's never
been a better time to buy a Jetta TDI
clean diesel it started when the German
automaker began a clean diesel marketing
push which suggested their cars were
environmentally friendly see how clean
it is it's not dirty but you still have
a dirty mind turns out clean diesel was
just a dirty lie
the automaker claimed it used a system
that helped convert harmful nitrogen
oxides a common type of air pollutant
into harmless nitrogen and oxygen Knox
are a family of gases that can cause
asthma bronchitis and contributes to
smog the U.S Environmental Protection
Agency required new diesel vehicles to
emit no more than 0.07 grams of knocks
per mile Volkswagen claimed it emitted
no more than 0.04 grams of knocks per
mile
so it was quite a shock when three
students at West Virginia University
tested two Volkswagen diesel cars and
found their missions were off the charts
they polluted way over the limit and all
of the five routes they drove in and
around San Francisco San Diego in La
according to their study the Knox
emissions for vehicle a the Volkswagen
Jetta were 15 to 35 times higher than
the EPA standards those for vehicle B
the Volkswagen Passat were 5 to 20 times
higher the car models were kept
Anonymous in the paper but we now know
their identities this chart is
especially revealing the green line way
at the bottom reflects the EPA emission
standards the two Volkswagens went way
over the allowed emissions
emissions for the Third vehicle they
tested a BMW X5 crept up only during the
hilly Drive the scientists thought to
themselves were they screwing up the
tests they couldn't be they had driven
the cars numerous times
they began to suspect something that
they didn't dare say out loud Volkswagen
was cheating it takes a lot of guts to
accuse a multi-billion dollar company
the second largest automaker in the
world of cheating but that's exactly
what Volkswagen was doing
the non-profit International Council on
clean Transportation which commissioned
the study by West Virginia University
turned its findings over to the
Environmental Protection Agency the EPA
later revealed Volkswagens were emitting
up to 40 times more pollutants than
Allowed by law not only did Volkswagen
deceive Regulators it deceived consumers
who believed they were purchasing
environmentally friendly cars so how did
Volkswagen manage to mislead everyone
it had installed software that could
detect whether the car was being driven
on the road or tested in a laboratory
when it noticed it was being tested in a
lab the software told the car to behave
by activating controls to temporarily
reduce emissions Inuit was being tested
in a lab when the car acted differently
Anna stefanopolu a professor of
mechanical engineering at the University
of Michigan explained to wired computer
sensors monitored the steering column
under normal driving conditions the
column oscillates as the driver
negotiates turns but during emissions
testing the wheels of the car move but
the steering wheel does it that seems to
have been the signal for the defeat
device to turn the catalytic scrubber up
to full power allowing the car to pass
the test a catalytic scrubber is a
device installed in the exhaust system
of a vehicle to reduce the emission of
harmful pollutants like nitrogen oxide
once the car was back on the road the
deceptive software would switch off
allowing it to again exceed the
standards when the researchers at West
Virginia University drove the cars on
the road they emitted far more
pollutants than when they tested the
same vehicles in a California laboratory
in the lab emissions were below EPA
regulations shown in green the
scientists did not explicitly accuse
Volkswagen of deception but it was clear
when you read between the lines Vehicles
A and B were operating as intended and
did not have any malfunctions in other
words this was no mistake the cars were
operating exactly as VW intended okay so
when they published their study in 2014
Volkswagen is freaking out but
Executives choose not to come clean or
admit to any wrongdoing even though the
California air resources board which
oversees Air Pollution Control efforts
in the state grew suspicious and did its
own tests Volkswagen argued that the
regulator's testing was flawed that the
outside air pressure affected the
results that the routes were
inconsistent and nevertheless Volkswagen
said it would update the engine software
for diesel cars starting with 2009
models you might think Volkswagen was
trying to fix the problem of excess
emissions but actually the recall
enhanced the ability of the software to
detect when the car was being tested in
other words Volkswagen used the recall
so that it could cheat even better
after the software update the cars did
emit less than they had but they were
still not within legal limits the
California regulator grew even more
suspicious and noticed emissions of
nitrogen oxides Rose after 23 minutes of
driving which happened to be one minute
after the end of a standard test cycle
Volkswagen was cornered and couldn't
come up with any more excuses
in September 2015 it finally admitted to
Regulators that its diesel cars were
equipped with software to cheat
emissions testing it was later revealed
that Volkswagen had been aware of the
cheating for years but had chosen to
keep it a secret the U.S Securities and
Exchange Commission claimed top
Executives knew about the fraud as early
as 2007. at the time Volkswagen's market
share in the U.S was a mere one percent
it was trying to do what it could to
compete with Toyota to become the
world's largest automaker yet it knew
its engines couldn't meet America's
stricter emission standards there were
also allegations of cheating and
emissions testing by other car companies
but none to the same extent Volkswagen
admitted that the software was installed
on 11 million of its cars most of them
in Europe where diesel-powered Vehicles
were popular at the time the company
recalled all 11 million vehicles to
remove the deceptive software and also
to retrofit the cars to meet emissions
regulations a time-consuming and costly
Endeavor but the biggest expense came
when Volkswagen had to pay about 30
billion in fines and settlements Which
is far more than it would have cost to
install adequate pollution control
equipment in the first place
several top Executives said Volkswagen
resigned including CEO Martin vintercorn
who maintained He was unaware of any
wrongdoing the company insisted that the
illegal software was just the work of a
couple of Rogue engineers
in the month following dieselgate
Volkswagen's worldwide sales fell five
percent there was even speculation that
Volkswagen was finished
yet Volkswagen was able to weather the
storm and is largely recovered in 2022
it was the second best-selling automaker
in the World Behind Toyota the company
regained consumer trust in part by
introducing electric and hybrid vehicles
advancing its commitment to sustainable
Transportation it is determined to sell
more EVS than Tesla by 2025.
but there's a long road ahead as
automakers have lost billions this
doesn't just affect you trying to buy a
car the everyday investor is getting
whacked by the tremendous price fall
because the S P 500 is the most popular
index used by the public to build their
personal wealth and it includes a lot of
exposure to automakers and their stock
but there is an asset class that has
outpaced the SMP by more than a hundred
thirty percent over the last 26 years
I'm talking about Contemporary Art the
Art Market used to be impossible to
access unless you were super rich with
Masterworks everyone can enter the
high-end Art Market without spending
Millions you can invest in multi-million
dollar artworks by Banksy basquia and
Monet all of the offerings have been
qualified by the SEC and every painting
Masterworks has sold to date has
returned to profit to investors the
results from these 11 paintings speak
for themselves
652 000 people have signed up for
Masterworks there's a wait list for new
users but you can skip the wait list by
clicking on my custom link in the
description